when i first started watching anime as
most do i began with netflix and amidst
the many wonderful shows at the time
that were readily available for my
prepubescent tastes there was one show
in particular that piqued my interests
fate zero
there's always something intriguing
about the battle royal concept in in any
form despite all of fate zero's best
attempts to confiscate the simple
concept with ponderous philosophical
vernacular and debate which i absolutely
love about the show by the way
but when reminiscing on this incredible
2011 series extending beyond just myself
and my personal love for the ethical and
moral debates it digs its teeth into the
often inspiring clash of old antiquated
doctrines compared to our modern ideas
what lies past that the common ground
that i can find with everyone that loves
this series is the animation of course
the studio behind works like the fate
series and demon slayer ufotable has
been famous for many years now arguably
ever since the aforementioned fate
series and its sequel fate's day night
unlimited blade works
later dubbed unlimited budget works by
fans because of the sheer magnificence
and peerless animation quality it
contained
but even this was nothing compared to
the studio's skyrocket in popularity
following the release of demon slayer
its most recent season cementing itself
as one of the best follow-up seasons to
date in anime and a promising
premonition of what is to come in season
3 which was of course already announced
mere days after the second season aired
its last episode but as i said ever
since i first started watching anime
i've been a fan of ufotable's work
dabbling in most of their anime both
shows and movies over the years i've
continuously developed an affinity for
the studio that really embodies the idea
of quality over quantity
today i wanted to peruse through the
studio's history some of the most
beautiful anime and stories they've
crafted and how they've cemented their
place among some of the biggest names in
the industry now with animation that
truly never fails
if you've only seen demon slayer or
haven't even seen any ufotable anime yet
you're in for a treat
long before the fate series or demon
slayer but a bit after what was a
multiple year stretch of pretty
forgettable works that the studio first
started out with a mixture of ufotable
original series and adaptations that
were
to put it simply not good euphoriable
got its first real kickstart with kara
no kyoukai or the garden of sinners a
seven part movie series aired between
2007 and 2009.
following yogosiki a demon hunter with
mystic eyes of death perception
as she well hunts and investigates
demons it's a series filled with action
mystery and badassery galore
based on the light novel of the same
name similar to the monogatari series
the series and its seven movies were
released in non-chronological order
adding both complexity and confusion to
the already heavy themes dealing with
the animus sin and reincarnation
ultimately concocting a good but
puzzling series
as much as i enjoyed it kara no
kyoukai's delivery of deeper ideologies
felt like a bit too much for me when i
first watched it making the rest of the
series feel like little more than a
slightly lackluster and muddled support
for the larger themes at play
i more so appreciate it for what it
stands as among ufotables works a well
made and very strong first attempt at
all of the things they did finally end
up succeeding with in the fate franchise
let me give a bit of context behind that
kara no kyoukai was the very first
project and light novel created by
writer kinokonasu and artur takashi
takeuchi better known as the co-founders
of type moon the famed japanese gaming
and publishing company as the very first
work from type moon it's only fair that
kara no kyoukai isn't the peak of their
production nor creative pursuits
and this is reflected in the anime just
as much as the light novel but it was
nonetheless a great start for many
reasons
ufotable's adaptation proved their
animation prowess at a time where top
tier animation wasn't nearly emphasized
as much as it is now
amidst the competition if it could even
be called that with guerin logon and
only a few other exceptional shows
exceeding the rather homogenized
standard of animation in the mid to late
2000s
ufotable's now signature combination of
cg and 2d animation was
at the time genuinely unprecedented
picture perfect scenery and backgrounds
smooth and visually stunning battle
sequences
it was more than enough to grab the keen
eye of many interested anime fans if
nothing else about the movies could
it also introduced some of the most
fundamental concepts in the overarching
universe of type moon's works to come
like the root counterforce magecraft and
mystic eyes the hints and intrigue of a
new larger universe at hand combined
with near perfect animation were
promising signs of what was to come from
the studio what could come
and patrons who remained faithful to
ufotable and typhoon's partnership would
soon have their dedication paid in full
starting in 2011 with the adaptation of
type moon's most acclaimed series and
first big hit
fate zero and the rest of the fate
franchise that would follow in suit for
the next decade
the fate series is easily one of anime's
most popular names
starting as the adult visual novel fates
day night in 2004 it spawned sequels
prequels and spin-offs in the form of
light novels manga series and even more
visual novels
multiple fighting games and one of the
most popular gacha games across the
western world fate grand order and anime
adaptations from two different studios
studio dean and ufotable the latter of
which being the famous and frankly good
one even within the vast type moon
universe fate has its own galaxy of
complex lore and a nearly endless throng
of characters and mixed up storylines
it's a lot
but if you follow just the anime by
ufotable it's actually quite digestible
and far easier to follow than its
complex web of adaptations makes it out
to be
in the fate universe the holy grail war
is a contest founded by three ancient
families centuries ago in which seven
mages each summon their own heroic
spirits or famed figures from the past
like king arthur of the round table and
the epic king of kings gilgamesh to
compete and obtain the holy grail a
source of endless power that grants a
wish to each member of the winning pair
or more so the last pair standing
fate zero a prequel that was actually
created after the original fates day
night follows kiritsugu hemia through
the fourth holy grail rule and fates day
night follows shido emiya through the
fifth holy grail war 10 years after the
events of fate zero in three different
routes
fate unlimited blade works and heaven's
field
now why are there three different
adaptations of the same story the
unfamiliar view might ask
this is usually a cause for concern for
new fans trying to get into the series
well visual novels which is of course
fate stay night's original format are
games that are driven by the player's
decisions
your choices decide whether you end up
on a good route or a bad one or a
neutral one but with a couple things you
didn't like and these are the three
stories of fate stay night that you can
end up on which happen to also be
associated with ending up with three
different girls
ufotable adapted fate zero in 2011
fate's day night unlimited blade works
in 2014 and heaven's feel in a
three-part movie series from 2017 to
2020
you can watch the original fate route
that was animated by studio dean in 2006
for extra credit if you want but
it's not really worth the effort
ufotables work on the fate series is
what really spread the good word around
because the studio and animators were
already familiar with takashi takeuchi's
art the animation only stood to improve
since the already astounding work done
in karanokyokai
and so what really works with ufotable
why are they able to stand out so
compared to other competitors why is
their style so distinct
a lot of reasons really
but first and foremost ufotable is one
of very few studios that does as much
work as possible in-house
most studios outsource animation
especially cg to freelancers and it
keeps prices lower but ufotable keeps
most works with just their employees
similar to the famed and beloved kyoto
animation
this extends to their cg work as well
boasting one of the largest in-house cg
studios among animation companies
and the reason that this doesn't
overwork their employees is because
unlike other certain studios
they don't overload themselves with
multiple projects at a time
looking at their videography you'll find
that there's very little overlap in the
production periods of their big projects
once again pointing at ufotable's idea
that if you're gonna do something
do it well
ufotable series with multiple cores or
more than 12 to 13 episodes are almost
always split into different seasons to
once again allow them time to create a
proper final product
take time and stun the world with what
they've crafted and unlike the name
unlimited budget work suggests
ufotable's insane production quality
actually stems from their independence
and dedication to each work rather than
some vast and endless budget for each
project it's because of this in-house
precise quality that they also have such
a distinct style of their own in
combining cg with 2d animation and
absolutely stunning backgrounds that
actually mirror that of real life
sometimes frighteningly so
without outsourcing the production stays
consistent and leaves fans remembering
and recognizing their signature style
that never fails to let us down
the fate series is also just great
source material
kinoko nasu and takashi takeuchi once
again teamed up on this work like in
karanokyokai which is no surprise here
considering what i just said about
ufotable's dedication to in-house work
and fate zero though it was still drawn
by takayuchi was written by gen urobuchi
who's won numerous awards for
screenwriting on famed anime like puella
magi madoka magicka which i recommend as
well another beautiful show from 2011.
fate zero received critical claim across
the board
a treasure brilliant masterfully crafted
narrative characters
and of course many of them mention once
again these stunning visuals
ifotable continued to improve and
improve with their tenure on the fate
series ending with the grand spectacle
of eye candy that is heaven's feel a
series of movies that truly feel
incomprehensively beautiful and well
animated
and then their long-standing success
with type moon which had certainly
already been enough to popularize the
studio on its own was quickly
overshadowed somehow
after the hottest new manga swept them
off their feet and took the world by
storm
demon slayer has rapidly become one of
the most famous anime currently out
there with its manga even surpassing one
piece the manga monolith itself in
copies sold the year before the series
ended what was a surprisingly short
serialization period
it's got great characters and all the
action you would expect of a shonen
powerhouse
but many actually dispute the series
fame and attribute it entirely to its
god to your animation from ufotable
which isn't really true or possible as
animation alone wasn't able to save say
2016's tales of zysteria of x and 2017
katsugeki token rambu from falling into
the abyss of ufotable's well animated
series that simply didn't have enough
else going for demon slayer hit the
jackpot frankly it was already a beloved
manga series in shonen jump that
received animation after being adapted
that elevated it beyond anything we
could have hoped for
one piece attack on titan haikyuu
there's there's so many famous series
that have experienced hate and
overwhelming complaints over sometimes
very minimal drops in animation quality
ultimately detracting from the fans
trust in the shows and the studios to
live up to the manga's quality let alone
exceeding it like they did with
demonstration
there's not much i can say about this
series that isn't already known but i
think it's unanimously agreed that it
keeps getting better
and i bet ufotable will continue to do
the same
as always this has been the anime
culture corner i hope you enjoyed the
video don't forget to like and subscribe
for future in-depth show manga and
character analysis